en la calle son de mi en parís nació
hace poco más de 15 días en colectivo
que reúne a artistas y asociaciones que
brindan ayuda a los refugiados las que
es uno de los artistas que participan en
el colectivo y quiere sensibilizar a la
opinión pública sobre los problemas de
la migración
aunque vengo del graffiti que es un arte
de lo instantáneo me parece que el hecho
de volver a las cosas reales y también
de escribir esta sociedad esta
actualidad ponerlo en las paredes
ponerlo en una pizarra es importante
solamente matarlos
así que estoy aquí para dar fuerza a los
refugiados aunque sea por poco tiempo
para darles un poco de ánimo
ah
la exposición tiene lugar en un edificio
de 5 plantas un gran espacio donde los
visitantes pueden moverse libremente por
un lugar dedicado a la creación como
apoño es miembro de la asociación united
muy grande para él es urgente renovar
los edificios abandonados para los más
necesitados
aquí hoy en el edificio tenemos una
veintena de personas alojadas que han
podido encontrar un techo esas personas
viven en la calle o son víctimas de
gente que se aprovecha de su situación
en realidad la idea es que cuando haya
edificios vacíos se ponga a disposición
de quienes más los necesitan
la exposición es efímera y a partir del
primero de enero comenzará a acoger a
familias refugiadas durante 15 días así
la idea es acompañar a los migrantes
durante el inicio de 2022
me parece muy bien que haya artistas que
se movilicen así por este tipo de causas
es algo muy fuerte aunque es algo
temporal les permite pasar un periodo de
invierno en el refugio la ciudad de
parís planea entonces reorganizarse para
acoger con urgencia a las mujeres y a
los niños que más lo necesitan
[Música]